todrick's oh you're fresh off the street
out of Oz tour and now look at us
you're on Broadway I'm so excited to be
here yeah how crazy is it to be back in
New York and starring in a Broadway show
it's insane I've always loved broadly
it's my first love it's what made me
want to sing dance and act as a young
child it talked to me about the journey
though because like you mentioned you
did leave New York to go to LA and do
the YouTube thing does it feel like it's
a full-circle moment now I think that
the whole point of like why it's such an
amazing thing to live in America in 2016
is because anything is possible I'm from
a farming community in Texas I would
have never dreamed that I would come to
New York let alone be in a Broadway show
let alone be starring in a Broadway show
and have a picture of my face outside of
a theater that I've walked past for
years every morning I wake up and pinch
myself and wonder like and might do I
still have the roll or hit like was that
just a dream Jesus Mary but this Mary
our rehearsals going and do you have any
nerves going into opening night do I
have any nerves the question that was a
grin like I know he's about the same I
am the most nervous I've ever been just
because this role is so iconic and it
means so much and what Lola stands for
is like freedom acceptance being who you
are like the last song in the show that
says just be who you want to be it's
just so beautiful because it's such a
simple lyric but something that we all
have to remind ourselves to do every
single day but the cast and the crew and
the creative team couldn't be more
welcoming and couldn't be more helpful
and they're giving me great notes I feel
so comfortable around them I feel like I
could fall on my heels and the entire
cast would pick me up talk to me about
what is the most challenging part of
playing Lola I think all of the separate
components by themselves are not that
difficult but when you put the hair and
the makeup and the makeup changes and
the wig and the costume adding all of
those components together and all the
lyrics and the music and singing live
and dancing in the boots all of it is
just a huge undertaking
how many costume changes are there I
have over 10 costume changes in the show
and every costume change
obviously Lola is a fabulous woman's
they come with a different shoe every
single time she accessorize is from head
to toe I have to ask did you get any
advice from RuPaul how to work
side him and also with the queens on
drag race he's given me just so much
life advice and the things that he's
told me about walking into a room and
just like being vulnerable because you
have to RuPaul has helped me really come
out of my show and be able to rehearse
pull out and just be more comfortable in
my skin because that's what he stands
for and you know you have a lot of
high-profile friends including Taylor
Swift have they offered any words of
encouragement or advice as you entered
this next chapter on Broadway Taylor's
been the person that I've been calling
the most when I'm freaking out because I
feel like she's just such I don't know
if I'm gonna say badass but she's just
such a badass and people knock her down
all the time for things that they say
about her relationships or whatever but
she stands on that stage with confidence
and she struts in those feels and she
does what she has to do every night and
she's been like todrick you got this
you're the most fierce person I know
I've been strutting in my heels for her
own FaceTime and stuff and she was like
I'm so excited to come and see the show
they're gonna have to put a like do not
let this girl into the show anymore
because she was like I'm literally gonna
be a kinky boots groupie so what do you
hope you know folks who come and see you
and see the show walk away with this
show is so awesome in it
it helps humanize what people think is
their ideal image of what a gay man is
or what a drag queen is and it's
impossible for you to come and watch the
show and not tear up and not cheer and
not cry my elementary school teacher
told me if you want to win people's
hearts over you need to be able to make
them cry or make them laugh but if you
can do both you have a fan for life and
this show does that I love that I pinky
swear I mean that if you come see the
show you will there will not be a dry
eye and there will not be a face not
smiling I want to see these boots in
person like it's no big deal come to my
dressing room dolly Harvey a little
backstage tour yeah so now you are
officially backstage so theater geek in
me is freaking out yeah well let's let's
take this theater geek to its first
steps onto Broadway stage
that'll be my Broadway dream your
Broadway fantasy I think a lot of
performers are like I can perform in
front of a nine thousand people more
than I can perform in front of two
people right everywhere so it's like
five people that say oh you know I need
the I need the full house yeah I think
you'd be great on Broadway anyway stop
it let me take you downstairs
haha this is the men's dressing room
you've never seen as many dresses in a
man's room but in this show this is the
norm so I fit in I can't imagine dancing
in this no one would have any clue that
this is this heavy like that's cool
choreo and I seen the shoulders like
kicks and there's what can I say oh no
talking about oh I have to heart okay
look at this detailing Gregg Barnes a
costume designer he's a Tony
award-winning costume designer he's
amazing I can tell but it just
everything is so detailed oh no you
gotta see the boots the iconic kinky
boots income men these are my boots so
those were tailor-made for you tailor
made Wow what size shoe are you I'm not
a ten and a half well again I'm a nine
go we can make it work can we can try
these on I would love to this is a
Cinderella moment home here to
straighten your leg it's a tall boot how
many people help you get into the booty
sharing just one okay that that slipped
on way to ladies gentlemen and those who
have yet to make up their minds
denne director dick assistant kinky
boots it gets us a kitchen
y'all got a bunch of wigs too right yes
because you can't be walking in heels
and a fierce dress with no way you're
right you're right and they have people
that are here all the time making sure
that all of the wigs are crisp and every
single performance gets the wigs at 100%
thank you so much for taking us
backstage like costumes hair on fleek
everything's amazing
um we IET you know we love you you're
got a few guys back we got you a little
gift a little a little good-luck charm
only keeping your dress yours rope any
night thank you so much it must be the
shoes that is so sweet
no you have a little good-luck charm
good luck Thanks oh you leave me no
break a leg break a leg break a leg but
don't break a boot but don't break don't
break your heel break a leg thank you so
much
et thank you guys for watching thanks
for watching ET on youtube if you like
what you saw all you got to do is click
to subscribe do it now